a precious and life-saving vaccine free
of cost and yet no one at this covet 19
vaccination center in downtown dakar
wants to take it some passerbys ask
nurse vintageallo if the vaccine will
make them sterile others wonder if it
will give them a heart attack or if
they'll go blind
despite her assurances the vaccine is
safe and could protect their lives
people don't trust her
[Music]
so much misinformation so much nonsense
talking about covert vaccines is like
talking about politics it has become an
issue that divides people let's make
this clear we need to get vaccinated to
protect ourselves and our loved ones
it's the only way
among those refusing to get vaccinated
is tv pundit and emergency doctor baba
karen young while he treats patients
infected with covet 19 nyang is famous
for his postings on social media he
argues that as long as western
pharmaceutical companies refuse to waive
patents so that vaccines can be produced
locally they should not be trusted or
used on africans
it's not a vaccine it's a product being
tested on people that's why people are
getting sick despite the vaccine
too much fear misinformation and not
enough vaccines means that only 10
percent of africans have been vaccinated
nigeria home to 200 million people is
only inoculated an average of a thousand
people a day
in senegal more than 200 000 expired
doses have been destroyed
this is where the covet vaccine is being
stored it needs to be kept between two
and eight degrees celsius the challenge
is to get those vaccines in remote
health centers where the ambient
temperatures is around 40 to 30 degrees
celsius also it's a race against time
for health workers to get as many people
inoculated before these doses expire
for nurse yellow the new variant is
spreading faster than we think partly
because of widespread misinformation
this vaccine hesitancy has a cost
perhaps barely visible for now but she
fears a wave of infections lies ahead
nicholas honk al jazeera dakar
let's uh talk about this with dr mocha
kamal yani who's a senior policy advisor
at the people's vaccine alliance he's
joining us from oxford in the uk thanks
for speaking to us on the al jazeera
newshour so um from what you've seen how
deep does
vaccine skepticism run in let's look at
the continent of africa first of all
okay so there is as your reporter said
there is the misinformation which spread
globally misinformation is everywhere
now what we have on top of that in in in
africa is the fact that there was no
supply so there wasn't communication
you know like a big communication
campaign to tell people what's this
vaccine about and how it can protect us
and all that the governments couldn't do
that because there was no vaccines so
here in the uk you know there was um
communication everywhere because if i go
to the clinic i will get a vaccine but
if i am in africa i won't get anything
so we don't have that communication so
that's one thing so people didn't
you know there was no vaccine so i
should worry about it and it was just
that the whole um like a sphere was open
to the misinformation so the the the
other the other thing is that um
now that i mean you mentioned ghana now
that ghana has um
you know that
there are some doses in ghana there is
some campaigning to um educate people
about the vaccines so there is more
people getting vaccinated in in ghana
and many other countries are like that
enough right you were talking about the
uk just a moment ago though um and you
were comparing the communication over in
the uk where you are to some countries
over in africa but despite there being
communication over in the uk there still
is vaccine hesitancy and skepticism um
over there as well as in parts of a lot
of countries in in eastern europe but
what do you put that down to
this these are different in in africa
there's lack of supply and
misinformation here the anti-vaxx power
movement or groups are very strong there
always have been um you know on measles
on other vaccines and now on covet but
now the social media is really
popularizing their message so a lot of
people are
skeptical about it in africa last
december so a year ago the african union
did a survey among a number of african
countries and most people said they are
um
they are um
they're willing to get vaccinated
because we're used to vaccines in africa
you know we vaccinate kids as a normal
part of life so having a vaccine is is
not a is just part of life it's not a
big deal but we didn't have the vaccine
while here people have the choice either
types of exceed or not we didn't have
that choice in africa right there is no
vaccine and that's it
you're you're part of the people's
vaccine and one of the things that your
organization calls for is equal access
to uh vaccinations what needs to happen
obviously we're not seeing equal access
as you've been saying parts of africa do
lack vaccines so what needs to happen to
to sort of make sure
that the vaccine reaches people who
who need it and want it
that was the problem the problem is rich
countries particularly rich countries
left three key decisions in the hands of
pharmaceutical companies and that is how
many doses to produce where the doses
are going and the price and therefore
the doses were produced according to the
company capacity they would prefer to
give them to rich market because that's
where they maximize their profit and you
know it's expected that between faith
and moderna by next year they will they
will have made a hundred billion billion
with a b billion um dollars next year
that never happened in pharmaceutical
companies history this is wrong what
we've been asking the people's vaccine
and other
alliance have been asking for since last
year any expectation of this even before
we had a vaccine is to diversify
production and maximize production all
over the world there are so many
companies colleagues have just published
a report yesterday about the number of
companies in developing countries that
could have made the vaccines and
therefore could have made more doses and
makes them available to these countries
we still have the option we still can do
that if the companies share the
knowledge about the vaccine there is an
mrna hub in africa and they're not doing
that they still want the monopoly we'll
have to leave it there
thank you thank you thank you so much
for speaking to us from oxford in the uk
dr monga kamal yani thank you